So this exercise that we've gone through with the clock radio, really is a,
an example of a process which you could use to do say chart modeling. And
here are the step that we went through. We prepared a use cases to start with of
typical uses of the clock radio. We determined the external percepts, that is,
what the user can see or hear or feel, with respect to the device.
We modeled those percepts with states, which may be corresponding to
currently executing state machines. We determined the external controls and
the stimuli or actions or user actions that could occur. In doing so,
we might model with additional states and, or add in additional transitions or
events. Then we began to consider the responses that the system have and
we did this with a table in which we listed. The various events and
the responses of the systems to those events. We added in some external
internal states or state machines to handle the timing situation.
We provided coordination mechanisms including the guarded transitions and
new internal events. And added any additional actions and
activities that the clock radio is required to do in order to implement, or,
or implement these particular responses, and
then we, we validated the resultant a state chart